[Music]
Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas's
daughter malty takes her first trip to
India everything that I am I learned in
the industry in India I don't have too
many tattoos I have a map of the world
on my arm here and when I put my arm
down India is right next to my heart the
mom and daughter visited a famous temple
in her home country that's pre and
one-year-old malty offering a prayer
while the priest performs the Puja the
Hindu worship ritual
the actress commemorated the special
visit with a few more picks of the two
next to the ancient Shrine sharing in
the caption that her first trip to India
had to be completed with a traditional
blessing I think as as parents it's
everything has a new meaning and has
even more meaning I am a Hindu and I
pray I have a temple in my home I do it
as often as I can but at the same time
to me I'm truly more spiritual I feel
I'm a believer of the fact that a higher
power does exist and I like to have
faith in that as for Nick and Priyanka
India holds a special memory it's where
they officially became Mr and Mrs in
2018. it was just three days
um one Indian ceremony and one
Western Christian ceremony and one day
of free rituals which we have in the
Hindu um in the Hindu wedding but it was
not like usually Indian weddings are
like thousand people at least we had
only 200 which was mostly family was
both of us both of us have giant family
knew once we locked in together that I
had a partner the life and a teammate so
I can walk to the good times and bad
times with and that was that was the key
[Music]
well things did get much better four
years later when baby malty was born I
think our daughter is the best gift that
we've ever received
she's loved and surrounded by a lot of
people but when she needs just me that
feeling is amazing it has changed
everything for the better of course and
um yeah I think it's just always about
doing the best you can to take care of
yourself and you never get it right 100
of the time but uh I I do my best and
now the trio is making memories together
like malty's first public appearance at
the Jonas Brothers Walk of Fame ceremony
to my beautiful wife the greatest gift
and I love being a parent with you so
multi-marie hi Ben
I can't wait to come back here with you
in 15 years and embarrass you in front
of your friends
and no doubt the families cherishing
their time in India the place that holds
a meaningful spot in their heart
[Music]
[Applause]